- See I feel like
marshmallows are like camping
and then Peeps are like glamping.
- Well, that's that on that fam.
(whips through air)
(hinge squeaks)
(fun music)
- Hey everyone, Emily here.
I'm super excited for Easter.
I want to share one of my
favorite family traditions,
toasting Peeps.
So I'm gonna gather some
of my friends at the office
and have them give it a try.
- There's two types of
people in the world,
those that hate Peeps and those that
love Peeps.
- Love Peeps, yeah.
- I think that toasted Peeps will taste
like magical heaven.
- Mm-mm.
- I'll give it a try, but
I make no promises, okay?
- We should have a pun about Peeps.
Let's Peep it up, that's weird.
(chick chirps)
I'm gonna take this blue one.
Oh, it's stuck.
- Uh oh.
First problem.
- It's like a personality quiz.
- We'll be pink twinsies.
- Okay.
- Is this work, it is working.
- I feel some heat.
- Oh this is actually so disturbing,
it's like watching a pink,
sparkly baby bird die.
(birds chirping)
- Well, when you put it like
that, now I'm more excited.
- I hope their eyes melt off.
- Oof.
- That's a little dark, isn't it? (laughs)
- Oh my God, I burned it.
Oh no, now my Peep can't see.
- I smell something.
- Oh look, oh, it's caramelized a little.
- Should I bite?
(horn honks)
(bell dings)
- I'm excited to be proven wrong.
- I'm just excited to eat these.
- I'm gonna have to eat this?
Jesus did not die for my
sins for me to eat Peeps.
- I think this means it's
ready if it's like slide.
Slide, slide, oh.
- Oh, oh, oh.
Okay, while you do you...
- What's happening?
- Okay, oh.
- I know we're not supposed to touch,
but I really am tempted.
- You're asking for trouble, man.
- Oh my God, yours is gonna fall.
- Yeah, yeah, oh my God, aah!
(record scratches)
(bleep)
Hot marshmallow is painful!
- I'm just gonna go for
it, I feel like it's ready.
Oooh.
(fun music)
- One, two, three.
(Peep crunches)
Oh my God!
- This is great.
I would eat these for breakfast.
- Why haven't I figured this out before?
- It has a nice, like,
toasted shell and the inside
is very gooey.
Mmm, I'm so into this.
- It's kind of better.
(hands clapping)
- But it doesn't taste
like anything, sugar air.
- Also, just like look at
that, like that looks crazy.
- A nice contrast between tough and soft.
Kinda like me and you.
- Ooh.
(laughs)
- So you've had a change
of heart, that's much.
- I'm in the middle now
because this is good.
I would do this at home
but be careful if you try this at home.
(fire crackles)
Please.
Oh my gosh, I remember in All That
when the lobsters used to come out.
(laughs)
- We are the dancing Peeps.
(fun music)
(whips through air)
(hinge squeaks)